actor Wilmer Valderrama stars as special
agent Nick Torres on the hit CBS show
NCIS which is in season number 20 right
now on part two of the season finale
next week agent Torres finds himself
undercover in prison as the NCIS team
tries to stop an impending terror attack
on American soil in the clip you're
about to see we see Torres keep his cool
as other inmates suspect who he really
is take a look
prison
and I'm sensing that right as you
what did you just say
sit down rat
oh you do talk I thought you just stood
there like a big
if you ever call me a rat again you're
next and your daddy is not going to save
you uh-oh Wilmer of all the Rama joins
us now Wilbur good morning I hope to
avoid that kind of reaction
I wanted to explain the bleep it's at
9pm yeah yeah
uh all right so NCIS as we said in the
introduction uh 20 Seasons it's been
connecting with audiences what do you
think the secret is
you know we get that question a lot and
I think
um it's it's pretty straightforward for
us I think that they've built a
configuration on the show where the
writers have been able to consistently
build and expand on the on the lead
characters and be able to make them
humans that actually feel that actually
have an opinion about the case
um everything they experience
professionally also really affects them
personally and I think that that that
makes it for a very personal invitation
for the audiences to be invested into
the the road in the journey for each
character and I think that's one for us
actors you know when you do a procedural
show and you do this many shows you know
you could tend to be like oh we know how
to solve a case now I'm going to make
this phase I'm going to do that phase
there's no way to you know we really we
really commit to to playing those beats
so I I think that's the that's the
secret sauce yeah but you said that the
finale is in your words bananas yes and
that you encourage them to think outside
the box yeah for this particular
character why what did you want what
because you get very very tough prison
face I'm scared sitting in there no I'm
safe in the studio
what did you want um you know I think
that when a show runs this long and
thanks to the grace and the beauty and
the Loyalty of all of our fans and
supporters you know you're going to have
this Runway and you understand the
television and live television has to
now eventually perform on streaming and
uh that we have to kind of
involve and and integrate some of those
elements that are working for people
that are now acquiring or adopting
streaming television so what what we've
been encouraging internally is to try to
figure out can we have some storylines
that that really get you invested to
watch the next episode and you know in
procedure shows you know the thing about
procedures is that you can watch a show
that case ends at the end of the episode
there's a new one the next episode
um but with a show that you know it's
going to get picked up next year or
something you know you can allow
yourself to dream a little and and draw
outside the lines and these writers have
done an incredible job of partnering up
with us and and keeping our story lines
personal yeah yeah the time the topics
are very timely this season your
character struggles with his own
immigration status when dealing uh with
an Afghan Refugee uh how close did that
episode hit for you it was very personal
uh for me because
um you know I as you guys know on the
U.S I'm the global ambassador to the Uso
and I've done almost 50 uh Uso tours
I've been to Iraq and Afghanistan
multiple videos and and I got to tell
you I was able to be underground in
Afghanistan to appreciate the
relationship that we have with our
allies on the ground and how our Afghani
you know soldiers in Afghani you know uh
Personnel really help our men and women
of uniform from the United States and
that to me was very personal so when we
did this episode
um it was it was almost
um liberating and very exciting to be
able to tell you know our home that
there was a different relationship here
and then no matter what person
perception we had what was happening no
matter what side you the conversation
was that
um that there was you know brothers and
sisters over there of of humanity that
really helped us for for the same cause
but in addition to seeing you on this we
can also see Vlad was saying yes back
what's that like to step back into that
role it was so real You Must Be Stopped
constantly on the street and people be
like yeah yeah they want me to say a
bunch of lines some inappropriate some
appropriate you know but it's it's um
look at you I know I love it the White
Pass was my idea
yeah and being on the hood like that for
my first the first shot that you saw me
was also my idea I thought you know how
can it be as as as aggressive as
possible
bring it fast
and that's what it's called we saw the
prison face and we saw The Fez
positioning there uh he can do it all
Wilmer Valderrama thank you very much
sounds great you can watch C part one of
the NCIS season finale tonight at 9 8
central here on CBS or on Paramount Plus